not going to lie to you I'm very I'm a
masculine ass female like you're not
going to tell me what to do you're not
going to tell me what to wear you're not
going to tell me where to go you're not
going to tell me you're not going to
tell me you're not going to tell me
you're not going to tell me you're not
going to tell me I'm going to tell you
how your future's going to end right now
yeah and that this is the thing ladies I
bet this guy is going to come in and say
the same thing but if you have that
mindset die alone what up guys welcome
to the just PE things YouTube channel
and welcome to my reaction series before
I start make sure you like the video on
your way in and subscribe to the channel
a like is the most important metc that
YouTube uses to push out these streams
so today I am reacting to man exposes
fake female influencers so I mean I
don't know what a fake female influencer
is but I I'm guessing either AI or women
on steroids I want to tell you guys a
story okay a couple years ago so I I'm a
heavy I'm a heavy lifter now I know the
comments will always say pearl but
that's so unfeminine you lifting and
okay I think there's worse habits to
have all right I I've just always
enjoyed lifting I don't I don't need I
don't want to be that jacked okay but I
I think it's it's just nice in my
day-to-day life to be strong Sumi okay
now there is this girl I met and I met
her through we were like it it was early
in my content creation days I met her
through this panel we used to do for
this like dating app they were coming up
with you guys don't even know I used to
do relationship quizzes I used to yep
yep I almost got a national TV for
relationship quiz because I would give
make quizzes for people I made quizzes
for people to send to their
ex-boyfriends girlfriends side chicks
the girl he cheated on you all this
stuff people loved them I had over
16,000 people take these quizzes my
first one which was like for your
ex-boyfriend anyways I met this girl us
women we can never get to the
point I met this girl okay and this girl
was telling me her lifting numbers and I
couldn't believe it so I'm 6 foot this
girl is like 56 okay and she told me she
could lift 350 lb deadlift now me the
highest I ever got okay I always say 300
it was 285 it was 285 but I round up I
round up okay anyways but that was
without like a belt or anything and she
told me 350 and I'm like how did this
chick she's like half my size your
weight's like important or whatever how
did she get 350 well I found out it was
drugs and this happens to me so much
okay I these chicks will like pick at me
or whatever and I'm like well how do
these women have zero wrinkles how do
they have these like tiny waist guys
they cheat
oh my gosh it's so funny they all take
these like drugs um you can take like
pills to be thin I I didn't understand
it for the longest time cuz I'm like how
do these women just get these like
perfect bodies out of nowhere drugs
drugs guys anyways yeah so I found out
this chick was on drugs and she was
trying to give me lifting advice and I'm
thinking [__] you're on you're on
literal drugs I
mean
anyways okay like you can't that that
chicks on
drugs drugs
[Music]
drugs be together or separate oh
separate chances are you have been here
before the chaos in the markets oil and
stocks just when you thought it was safe
and interest rates were Rising new
threats come out of nowhere tensions are
boiling from Asia to Europe and
adaptation is the key here to
safeguarding your wealth you may not
have considered gold before and it's not
speculation but insurance and right now
you need some insurance Noble gold
Investments has been protecting
investors from disaster for years with
precious metals so if you're worried it
might be time to take a fresh look at
gold and silver gold is a proven Safe
Haven shield for your portfolio and a
volatility balance against uncertainty
if it helps Noble gold Investments is
offering a free 3o silver America virtue
coin with its new IAS this month if you
open up your Noble gold Investments Ira
or 401K rollover you can claim your coin
today remember crisis free portfolios
waiver and gold insulate secure yourself
against all threats go to noblegold
investments.com now that's Noble gold
investments.com the only gold company
that I
trust and I never understood because
half the time I mean these women do have
to put in hours at the gym it's not
drugs alone and I think to myself why
would you want to make yourself look
like a dude now I'm not talking about
you know there's some women that are
just kind of naturally built like that
but that that you were doing something
to make yourself look like that's not
natural ex me where's the bathroom that
[Music]
way how much can you bench probably not
as much as
me most natural physique I've seen all
day someone said yes I'll do the cooking
yes I'll do the cleaning like why would
you look like that I mean the worst part
is I I feel like she could have been
pretty at one point but what have you
done what did you
do
[Music]
are you natural or not oh come on but
okay even her clearly she spent hundreds
of hours in the gym why why wouldn't you
look like a hottie why I'm just be
waiting for this question so tell me
what do you and I'll tell you I lift a
lot of weight all right I'm pretty
strong that is not an easy physique I
mean I don't know anything about drugs
so if you if you the the drugs they give
you I don't know
but life oh well yeah no um I honest
opinion do you compete not anymore no so
you used to I used to 5 years ago in the
amateur League oh my gosh why are you
even yes she's H drugs duh you my guess
is no why would you say
no no
way doesn't matter what I say people
will still believe what they will
believe people will believe what they
want to believe but what's your answer
my answer is that I'm natural lifetime
natural you the competing days yeah I
mean I was an amature I did it for that
was sing That's What I Call sing simp
simp simp simp he's telling her what she
wants to hear he's trying to bang what
are you a
[__] awesome you [__] [__] and I
still live for fun I live for the real
passion of lifting weights I don't have
I've lifted for 10 years no no of
getting bigger I don't have a goal of of
course everyone wants to always be lean
but I also know that it always comes
down to how I eat like that's the main
thing and so yeah I'm natural a natural
born liar if she's natural then I'm a
white lesbian
woman is this name archon archon
Aon AR Arco Arco Arco it's like we're
reacting together look at this we're
like buddies look at it he makes such
good
compilation
a says in the caption That's How I Met
Your Mother in 2023 if you do this in
the gym and you're a man that's how you
go to jail you're going to jail you're
going to jail should we start trying
that lady's falling I'm just kidding she
just don't need my help why I got to be
me for back up back up back up in set
back up bro if you're not scared of help
her just go help her I'm busy you don't
see me doing a set how about you go help
just cuz she has a tripod you're not
going to help her no I'm doing a say you
smart I can't make this [__] up Paige
hway welcome to the show I saw it 15
seconds ago page out the way 3.6 million
followers just wait say she put it on
her story she's advertising for this
waist snatch and bodysuit and she
[__] posted the edited photo and then
the unedited photo back to back yeah I
found that out all these chicks are Ed
in their pics and then they'll come at
me for my looks and I'm like chica is I
see your filters I don't even know what
you look like I I see them I mean don't
get me wrong I have some good lighting
but you guys distort your entire body
it's embarrassing it's so embarrassing
aren't you guys like wives mothers so
the world gets a better version of you
than your husband yeah okay clicked the
wrong one in her
camera what a idiot look at
the what an absolute donor and she's not
the only one a lot of these gym
influencers and only fans girls with the
perfect bodies are faking it they're
using Photoshop what you see is not what
you get so don't feel [__] about
yourself when you see these perfect
people online cuz most of the time
they're
lying I'm built different I always say
that about me I'm built different I'm
built even more
different and that is how you crack and
ache oh my
god wow most of the evidence out there
shows that us that weight loss is
actually not good for our health in fact
if you want to pretty much guarantee
that you're going to be heavier 5 years
from now the best thing that you can do
is go on a diet because that's actually
the greatest predictor of a weight gain
oh no oh no what the [__] are you
talking about I'm fat because I drink
too much red wine and I don't exercise
enough that's not true that's absolutely
not true I how do you know my red wine
consumption well I mean but you are not
F you not fat because of what you eat
and how much exercise you do that okay
and I'll tell you if someone has been in
the gym for years I've never really
stopped going to the gym I know I know
all these chicks pick at me whatever I
have been in the gym for a decade I have
ran a marathon I've deadlifted all right
285 lbs I round to 300 all right squat
250 I've done yoga before I've done so
many different Fitness stuff except a
dance class I kind of want to do that at
some point but nothing mattered unless I
ate less except marathon training I will
say that just makes you drop weight like
crazy nothing mattered unless I ate less
nothing I I got to be pretty fat right
after college it was so embarrassing
because I just blew cuz I I was used to
burning so many calories a day and then
I stopped working out so much because
volleyball ended and I was just like I
saw a picture of me the other day from
that time embarrassing it's the line
that everybody is led to believe but
there was if I if I left you now and ran
up and down Leicester Square for 3 hours
and then went home and had a piece of
lettuce and then came in and did the
same tomorrow and the day after that and
the day after that I would start to look
like a superm model uh only for a few
months and then you would stop in fact
you would start regaining weight within
the first year even if you only ate
Letts and ran around L Square for 3
hours that is a fact that's not fiction
are you delusional do do you suffer from
a mental illness that is a absolute fact
even if you took that skinny jab that's
out on the market now you'd still end
upic I think it's called OIC is OIC you
would end up gaining the weight that is
how the body works the body will always
return you to your natural set point
weight yeah but don't you couldn't your
natural state be like a thin one your
set point they don't goes by the name
the fat doctor and says that she's a fat
that's why I say you can get like a
study to literally say anything
literally huh but the truth is she
started making Tik Tok videos about a
weight loss Journey but realized she was
too lazy and weak-minded to do it so she
just spun it and made it into a fat
activist page and now she says
ridiculous things like you've just seen
she's just a joke that people use for
Content I'm
no oh my God that man that man look me
in my eyes said screwed I'm going to end
Ito did she play soccer
yes damn wow the young ladies today
they're not learning from Mom how we
losing recipes you know what I'm glad
that he's talking about this there's not
enough yeah I I don't think we've had a
real wife in like 50 years it's been
like half a century since we've had an
epitome of like real wives that actually
knew how to do traditional housework my
opinion but uh it really is sad the
amount of recipes we're losing it's not
sad it's
devastating Los
[Music]
recipes so 100,000 women went on strike
today in I demand gender equality the
entire and no one noticed cuz we suck
yeah we we I mean honestly guys I enjoy
what I do I really do I really do but
could the world live without female
commentators could the world live
without human resources yeah could we
live without plumbers electricians
contractors no women's jobs are much
less useful than men's jobs in general
70,000 so over 25% of the population
went on strike and I have some crazy
news for you the economy did not come to
a stop and it continued as normal the
only memo I got was that HR departments
were getting no complaints for the the
24 hours that the women were on strike
and um men were that's amazing I I bet I
bet you was better because then women
weren't gossiping at work wrting that
they were really sorry women didn't get
gender equality but I heard uh one CEO
said it was nice to finally get some
done 17 18 okay if you were born 6 years
ago how old would you be 11
6 if you were born 6 years ago if you
were born years old 6 years old would
you be I think this was on a college
campus this is so embarrassing you were
born 6 years ago yeah how old would you
be 11 you are really dumb for real do
you know what country the great role of
China is
in country
yeah if you had to
guess Japanese oh
no no no she didn't even say a country
she just said a nationality bro she
needs Michael get some
help raising cream pies I'm raising one
right here
here good
one
you
away you look like a
fornite the first Olympics and you swam
honestly your third leg was just
phenomenal yeah I mean I haven't
actually had a chance to watch it back
yet i' I've tried to find it
and I'm not going to lie to you I'm very
M I'm a masculine as know like you're
not going to tell me what to do you're
not going to tell me what to wear you're
not going to tell me where to go you're
not going to tell me you're not going to
tell me you're not going to tell me
you're not going to tell me you're not
going to tell me I'm going to tell you
how your future's going to end right now
yeah and that this is the thing ladies I
bet this guy is going to come in and say
the same thing but if you have that
mindset die alone I mean it's fine I'm
I'm a little bit more easygoing than the
tradcons okay now a lot of people a lot
of people think she just wants every
chick to get married no no I don't want
some of you to torture men for a
lifetime no no some of you should really
die alone I mean this now don't don't
get me wrong don't get me wrong we
definitely need more women to get
married but I mean do we need these only
fans models making more children I don't
think so I don't I don't think so at all
cat lady 10 I'd say I'm a 10 10 10 10
come on tens what would you rate
yourself Brian six 6.5 on a good day do
y'all are
perfect
yep yeah brao come on if you guys are
tens then there's no girl that's better
looking than you I love all women every
girl is a 10 every woman all right let
me let me let me I'm GNA rank him every
guy a 10 no okay so this chick honestly
if she dressed she's a little overweight
five six here but I think she makes
herself a five because of the fake stuff
I don't like that um this chick four
hold
who every woman's a 10 but not every
guy's a 10 as this guy says they don't
even add up to to
10 yeah what's up what's up I paid for
it what's
[Laughter]
up so how do you know when a woman's
about to say something smart oh I can't
wait to hear this when she starts by
saying a man once told
me
goty right y haha how many men does it
take to open a beer none it should
already be open when you bring it to
me
[Laughter]
[Music]
in the span of 24 hours I had one man
tell me that nobody will date a girl
with a
kid and then I vented to another guy
about the person who said that and then
he told me no that's not true but a man
doesn't want to date a girl who slept
with a lot of
guys two for two and you guys think
fresh and fit are mean you think I'm
mean but when women don't have this
information this is what it leads to oh
well if it isn't the consequences of
your own actions you made your bed now
you got to lying it what do you look for
on him man oh I can bear almost anything
as long as he has clean teeth I look for
kindness and sincerity most of all I
think personality warmth and affection
for children are I got to be honest I
got to I got to be honest guys I don't
think the women from the 1960s were that
different I think they still selected
for the same exact things women select
for today and you could see this because
a bunch of them divorced their husbands
I mean they could virch you signal here
but I mean a lot of them still ended up
divorcing or separating with the guys
that have the warmth and affection for
children they're saying the right things
I'm just saying I don't believe that
women were that different ever I just
think there was more social shame number
one and there were more societal
barriers that kept women from you know
there's a reason like the father would
say stay away from my daughter cuz he
knew his daughter loved she loved him
she we love the criminals you know I
don't know really physique interest do
you think look to
important sometimes so depends on the
man what about money but also do you see
how different their looks are the women
today all look the same it's like little
bit of boto their foreheads don't move
the the beauty back then was just like a
different type of beauty money is not
important would you marry an ugly man
I've married one what's your craziest
compition dang my boyfriend with a guy
who told me I told him not to wor about
every girl here is 9 out of 10 as L look
10 out of
about fellas I don't care how good she
looks in fact the better she looks the
less you should do this and that's put
them on a pedestal and start pandering
to them like these fellas are doing
they're not going to respect you or take
you seriously long term when you act
like this if you treat them like a
celebrity they're going to treat you
like a fan you believe in God I don't
don't think he does either don't believe
in God Christian on you man sorry sorry
oh wow you guys not together or no I've
just met him I assumed he doesn't you
guys got home I'm I'm disgusted that's
all right I reckon that man just saved
him and he dodged a bullet how she going
to call him disgusting for being a
Christian what that that girl is that
guy go back that man just saved him and
he dog the that guy is way better
looking than her look at that that is NI
she going to call him disgusting for
being a Christian why ain't saying she's
got to she looks like pregnant just e
she can believe what she wants but the
fact she reacted like that over that
something a right so my girlfriend told
me she's out with family and she forgot
that I have her location and she's at
this bar so we're about to pull up on
her I wonder if she's cheating with a
man or a woman I bet she's cheating with
another Chi she's really
doing really are you being joking right
now yeah talking to lesbians about their
experienc dating is quite funny
actually hey babe I thought you were out
with family
who's this hi this is my girlfriend oh
my gosh what a downgrade not
anymore
okay thanks yeah it's an evil world we
live in if she cheats she belongs to the
streets well I like this guy I'm going
to subscribe look at this subscribed get
this guy to a million followers Arco TV
okay guys let me know what you think in
the comments okay make sure you like the
video on your way out And subscribe to
the channel and let me know tell me a
story about a girl that you thought was
natural and then ended up not being
natural cuz that's happened to me men I
think have a better eye for it cuz when
I talk to guys about this they can like
tell a lot of times I don't notice but
then later I find out I'm like oh I'm
like drugs anyways like the video on
your way out guys subscribe to the
channel I'll talk to you next
time